continue de parler de cette journée de
mobilisation avec bruno pomart en direct
avec ce policier du raid et auteur de
l'ouvragé flics d'élite dans les cités
aux éditions anne carrière
bonjour bonjour bruno pomart merci de
répondre à nos questions comment est-ce
que vous appréhendez cette journée est
ce que vous craignez des débordements
des violences avec donc une
manifestation autorisée celle de
génération identitaire à denfert
rochereau une autre qui ne l'est pas car
déclarés hors délai celle des nouveaux
des mouvement d'ultragauche du côté de
montparnasse
bah écoutez je vois que vos journalistes
ont bien résumé la situation de côté
évidemment une manifestation qui
déclarait donc encadré et sécurisé comme
c'est le cas avec génération identité en
aviron partagent pas nécessairement les
mêmes avis mais c'est comme ça c'était
de façon démocratique et d'un autre côté
les ultra gauche dont on connaît
évidemment le les mouvements de violence
qu'ils sont capables on l'a vu à
diverses manifestations lorsqu'on sait
qu'elle était à et tous les militants
qui sont autour on peut s'attendre
effectivement à ce qu'il y ait des
débordements et le risque pour nos
policiers qui sont en nombre et qui sont
habitués malheureusement à ce type de
manifestation c'est d'éviter évidemment
qu'une confrontation entre les deux on
voit la fin va être le gros morceau je
dirais de l'après midi évitez compte
tenu des distances à peu ça peut le
faire sans problème en termes tactiques
techniques mais encore une fois nos
policiers vont être là présents et ils
vont devoir faire preuve de beaucoup de
lucidité et de discernement de ceux dans
ce type de manifestation qui oppose de
km2 extrêmement nous parler du
dispositif policier on a entendu surtout
neige abderrazak parler de ce dispositif
policier également david khalifa on
annonce une équipe mobile des forces de
l'ordre étaient censées être déployés
pour intervenir rapidement en cas de
troubles ça veut dire quoi se dire
combien d'hommes quel type d'équipement
écoutez il ya onze 11 compagnies qui
sont obligés d'après des informations
que j'ai ça veut dire les compagnies de
crs et de gendarmes au clic sont
traditionnellement sur les
manifestations à encadrer des
manifestations et vous avez les braves
et les brigades de répression des
actions violentes qui sont là les braves
m comme on appelle les browns mike cole
dire bon ton dans l'équité moto pour
pouvoir intervenir
évidemment rapidement sur les qui
conclut ce culte qui pourrait se
détacher éventuellement des
manifestations pour une syrie aller au
contact des autres donc il va falloir
avoir des éléments très mobiles qui sont
capables
de revenir comme on l'a vu à l'occasion
de notre manifestation soit capable
d'intervenir très rapidement pour
neutraliser au sens également les
critères que je dis neutraliser de façon
à éviter que les confrontations et des
violences la seule chose qu'il faut
espérer c'est encore de quoi les titres
à gauche ne s'entraîne pas à nos
policiers évidemment parce que c'est
toujours la facilité et on sait on sait
leur position par rapport à la police de
façon générale vous parler
d'intervention de light comment est ce
que vous vous analysez vous êtes vu les
images un adage abderrezak nous l'a
montré
l'interpellation de jérôme rodriguez
l'une des figures des gilets jaunes qui
est donc du côté de montparnasse avec
les militants d'extrême gauche
écoutez faux pas de la provocation je
pense que j'ai un regret je le connais
bien je n'ai côtoyé plusieurs fois ce
n'est pas très gai il est dans la
provocation ici c'était interpellé je
suppose que les policiers ne l'ont pas
fait compte-tenu vous le savez que les
médias sont présents que les les caméras
et les téléphones sont présents ils
n'ont pas fait par hasard ça veut dire
qu'il ya sûrement une provocation et si
les policiers l'ont interpellé ce qui
avait de bonnes raisons
voilà tout simplement laissons faire la
situation encore une fois encore on sait
que c'était un personnage évidemment qui
est tonitruant étiez capable de monter
la pression comme on dit les quais
sûrement été appelés pour de bonnes
raisons
on a souvent pointé les fatigue
récurrente des forces de l'ordre
manifestation après manifestation dans
quel état d'esprit sont vos collègues
cet après midi en vue de cette double
manifestation est ce que vous avez des
retours des échos bah oui oui j'ai des
décos évidemment de mes collègues qui
sont sur le terrain qui sont là présents
comme toujours
malgré des situations de toujours de
plus en plus complexes mais ils sont
présents et encore une fois je pense que
jose nery que le gouvernement sera
encore une fois être présent puisque
vous savez qu'actuellement le pauvre de
la sécurité est en place pour apporter
des solutions des réponses à l'eau aux
anneaux en haut fonctionnaire de police
est ce parce que ce aujourd'hui encore
nos policiers malgré la fatigue malgré
la pression seront présents en nombre
pour assurer la sécurité de ces
manifestations de côté une manifestation
qui est déclarée autorisé d'un autre
côté de manifestations qui n'est pas
autorisé et effectivement qu'il est pas
non plus encadrée en termes de service
d'ordre donc c'est un véritable problème
pour nos forces de l'ordre mais j'en
suis sûr le
la démo pc qui est la direction de
l'ordre public sera présente un nombre
évidement avec cette fameuse braves qui
seront là pour intervenir dans les
meilleurs délais pour éviter toute
confrontation
outre votre casquette d'ex policiers du
raid vous êtes également maire de
belflou en occitanie d'où cette question
politique
gérald darmanin qui menace donc de
dissoudre un mouvement d'ultra droite
d'un côté et qui de l'autre semble dans
la surenchère sécuritaire on l'a vu ces
derniers jours notamment avec ses propos
face à marine le pen comment est-ce que
vous analysez cette position semble-t-il
ambiguë de la part du ministre de
l'intérieur
écoutez je pense que je ne dis pas que
gérald darmanin chercher un équilibre
puisqu'il sanctionner les les mouvances
islamistes qui sont présents en nombre
sur notre pays
en fermant des mosquées ou des
associations tout simplement
c'est une bonne chose suri génération
identité a bien écouté le ministre a
fait ce qu'il avait à faire
après les sont encore une fois la
justice a décidé puisque les générations
identitaires ont été plusieurs fois
blanchi sur des opérations en termes de
judiciaire donc laissons faire une fois
encore la justice mais je crois qu'il
faut être toujours prudent mais ne pas
faire encore une fois et nous avons tous
tendance à le faire à travers sociaux
faire la justice avant la justice donc y
laissons le tribunal décider de ce qui
sera fait par rapport à cette
association tout simplement s'il doit
être dissoute pour les propos qu'elle
tient mais inversement jour dire il ya
des propos qui sont tenus et là serait
pas c'est pas le mouvement c'est une
personne en particulier mais qui
appartient la française je pense bande à
bono qui a fait des déclarations parfois
en comparant les noirs et les blancs de
façon assez catégorique on peut se poser
aussi des questions sur sur ses
positionnements qui son apport pour le
moins raciste donc après posons nous les
bonnes questions aussi
est ce qu'on reproche à génération
l'identité incertaine l'opposition est
ce que c'est
judiciable ou pain et de notre côté mme
alain bourneau qui nous fait des
déclarations comme on le sait et est le
comparateur on n'en parle pas donc voilà
c'est c'est de trouver un équilibre et
la justice est là pour ça quelqu'un quel
arbre a tout simplement et que quant au
droit des réponses à toutes ces
problématiques et merci à bruno pendant
avoir répondu à la question je rappelle
que vous êtes
exposition
du real auteur également de l' ouvrage
flics d'élite dans les cités aux
éditions anne carrière